today on the matt walsh show many
republicans rejoice as caitlyn jenner
runs for governor
they're very excited about the prospect
of a republican transgender governor but
can the right defeat the left by fully
embracing and accepting its fundamental
claims about gender
consider me skeptical also five
headlines including the family of
micaiah bryant calling for police reform
uh democrat representative admits to
emotionally abusing her daughter and
terrorizing her over thoughts of
impending doom because of climate change
the oscars announced the winners but
nobody's ever heard of any of them and a
new study reveals that the six-foot
social distancing guideline
is totally arbitrary and baseless they
tell us now after a year all of that and
much more today on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
so it was announced on friday that
caitlyn jenner would be running as a
republican for
governor of california reading now from
a cnn article announcing the big news
it says quote jenner a long-time
republican filed paperwork
in los angeles county and announced her
intent on her website
again i'm reading from the article on
cnn this is their language not mine
her bid is one of the most high profile
campaigns by a transgender person in the
country
california has been my home for nearly
50 years i came here because i knew that
anyone regardless of their background or
stationary life could turn their dreams
into reality jenner said news release
but for the past decade we have seen the
glimmer of the golden state reduced by
one party rule that places politics over
progress
and special interests over people
sacramento needs an honest leader with a
clear vision
um jenner who described herself
in the announcement as a disrupter and
denounced newsome's impact on the golden
state began exploring an entry into
politics early
this year and has been working with a
close group of gop strategists to lay
the groundwork
for her gubernatorial bid all right so
it goes on to explain that some of
some members of trump's team are now
working with jenner also some former
romney advisors are on board
romney and trump famously hate each
other but it's nice to see that the two
sides could come together for the sake
of
giving america its first transgender
governor this is the kind of project
that the modern republican party can
work together to achieve they can't do
literally anything else
no matter how much power you give them
but this they can do
well they can't even do this actually
because he almost certainly isn't going
to win
so they're either going to fail at this
as far as qualifications to hold elected
office
jenner has none to speak of he also has
almost no qualifications to be
considered a conservative
we're talking about conservative here
only in the sense of supporting
tax cuts and using phrases like the free
market and
fiscal responsibility enough of the
special interests
but when you go even just an inch below
the surface
jenner is of course nearly as liberal as
any other liberal in california
the only good thing that can be said
about jenner's run for governor is that
it doesn't really matter who the
governor of california is
the state is a disaster zone a parasitic
lump
of fixing itself to the rest of the
country and that won't change whether
the governor is an outright left-wing
liberal
a democrat or a left-wing democrat
masquerading as a milquetoast republican
the result is the same that's why the
real significance of jenner's run
is how it's been received by those on
the right and what that reception
says about contemporary conservatism now
from what i've seen
many self-professed conservatives have
celebrated the news believing apparently
that having a prominent trans republican
on the team
will enhance our cultural credentials
the idea is that we can we can play the
left's own game and beat them at it
it's only days until we start hearing
republicans say things like see
democrats are the real transphobes got
you now
libs in the process many conservatives
have fully adopted
the language rules of the left making
sure for instance to use
female pronouns when referring to jenner
who is by the way a male
one example a small right-wing account
on twitter put out a tweet with a
picture of nikki haley
and caitlyn jenner standing next to each
other and said that the photo
illustrates
uh the downfall of the gop dean
kane responded saying that the tweet was
funny and then and he was laughing at it
um nikki haley herself responded to kane
with this
interesting i don't find it funny
caitlyn
came to see me at the un and i
appreciated her conservative views
i will continue to think that the
republican party is one of conservative
views
by all people regardless of their
demographics to me that's not funny
it's america now i agree with the last
part at least
this isn't funny i mean maybe it's a
little funny
there's of course some delicious irony
in the idea that the first female
governor of california
could be a white male republican and if
jenner's run was embraced solely in that
spirit
in the spirit of trolling i could
almost support it
but that's not what's going on here at
least not among prominent people on the
right those in positions of power and
influence nikki haley isn't trolling
anyone
the republican advisors in generous
orbit aren't trolling
and that's why i find it necessary to
make two points here
two really important points putting
aside the trolling element of this
because again i i know that's going to
be the responsibility isn't it funny
i get it yeah that that's kind of funny
but there are two things that are more
important
number one language matters
the left realizes this and they've
always realized it
that's why they spend so much time
controlling and policing language
we're so dumb that we've always chalked
this up to leftists being a bunch of
over-emotional snowflakes
that's not it the emotional snowflake
stuff is a tactic
and an effective one the point is to
shape what people think
by shaping the words they use
because that's how our minds work
now when you use the word she in
reference to a man
like jenner you are agreeing with the
proposition
that the person you're referencing is a
woman that's what you're saying
when you say she what you're
communicating is the person that the
person you're talking about
is a woman now you may not
believe that yourself but you're saying
it
you're lying you are participating in
the lie
you are in fact participating in the
entire lie of left-wing gender theory
you are adopting and and agreeing with
all of it
through that one simple word she
you have just conceded the left's entire
agenda
with respect to gender and sex and by
conceding that
you've conceded essentially everything
because gender theory rests on the
philosophical premise of relativism
which you know there's no objective
truth truth is whatever i feel it is
whatever i think it is
that's gender theory if a man feels like
he's a woman thinks he's a woman then
he's a woman
that that can't be true
unless relativism is true of course as
we know relativism can't be true because
the whole point of relativism
is that nothing is really true yet if
you say relativism is true
then you are defeating relativism just
simply by saying that but
whatever the point is um
relativism serves as the foundation of
the left's
basic ideas and doctrines all of them
by using the words they tell you to use
you give up the whole game
you give it all up if you think i'm
making too much of it
then consider again why they make so
much of it
why is it so important to them that you
use
certain words
and we can't even use the oh it's polite
excuse
now i don't think it's actually polite
to tell a lie
to participate in a lie to participate
in a person's delusion i don't think
that that's
that's polite at all but most of the
time we're talking about occasions
when you're referring to someone but
they're not there
you're you're talking about them when
they're not even around
polite there's no courtesy there
but even in that case especially in that
case
the left makes it very clear this is the
word you're supposed to use why do they
care so much
well this is why it's not because
they're emotional
it's because they know that if you can
control the words people are using you
control the ideas
that people have you control reality
but this has been the concern this has
been conservatism's mo for a long time
conservatives think they can concede all
of the most fundamental points
adopt the left's whole philosophical
framework and yet still win in the long
run
by electing republicans who will cut
taxes and talk about limited government
it doesn't work it's never worked it
cannot ever work
second point you can't
beat the left at its own game
okay leftists aren't thrown for a loop
by the fact that there's a trans
republican
all these dummy conservatives saying i
see we got them now
what are they going to do this time
got it backed into a corner we got it
there's a trans republican
they they they have no problem simply
saying that jenner doesn't count that
he's a traitor to the cause that he has
internalized
transphobia or whatever they've got
plenty of things they've got plenty of
stock answers
in these kinds of situations now it
might be fun for a while
when the campaign gets going to accuse
democrats of being
transphobic if they criticize gender but
jenner but that tactic doesn't actually
work or achieve anything
now conservatives often try the same
thing with race democrats accuse
republicans of being white supremacists
and so republicans ever lacking an
imagination respond by saying
no we aren't you guys are the real white
supremacists
it's an easy response but it achieves
nothing and i'll tell you why
because you cannot beat someone at a
game
they invented where the rules can be
changed by the inventors
at any time it's impossible
this is their game they own it
they make the rules and the number one
rule is
you can't win that's the number one rule
no matter what you do or say
if you choose to play that game with
them you cannot win
so when it comes to anything but now
we're talking about gender theory the
left's ideas about gender
if you decide to dive in and say all
right i'll play this game
i'll show you how it's done no you lose
you've adopted their whole framework
you've agreed with their underlying
premise
you lose we lose everything
if there is any winning at this point
it's by refusing to play that game
and one way to refuse to play the game
is by using words in the way that
they're supposed to be used
conveying truth when you speak
that's what we should be doing
refuse to play the game
all right let's get now to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know one of the great uh pleasures
of parenthood is is listening
to your kids have conversations at least
at a certain age and i mean
conversations not when they're bickering
and fighting and that sort of thing
because they do a lot of that but
sometimes you'll catch them just having
normal
sort as normal as they can conversations
which which could be really funny so on
saturday i had the boys
uh my seven-year-old son my
four-year-old son in the truck with me
were driving to
i don't know where i can't remember now
but they had this long discussion
debate about how it is that that people
who are currently dead
can be seen on tv
and the my oldest son had just recently
learned
um because we were watching something
and i remember we were watching but
but he and there was an actor on tv he
was he was asking me about that person i
said oh he's he's uh
that person's dead and you could just
see the wheels turning and my son's
like wait dead i'm looking at him right
there so they were debating this you
know how is it possible and what they
settled on the answer they settled on
is that anytime you see a dead person on
television
that's a robot and so
the people who make movies they have
some sort of laboratory where they go
and they create robots of the dead
people
so the dead people can keep appearing in
movies and tv
good answer you know it's working with
your way through a problem not coming to
the right
conclusion but that's this is critical
thinking in its earliest stages
this is another one of those times where
the kid version of reality
is so much cooler than the real version
now i feel kind of bad because one day
they're going to realize that no it's
not
it's not quite that cool or nearly as
cool as that unfortunately
all right number one cnn um reports on
what exactly led to the altercation
with micaiah bryant where she tried to
um
stab someone to death and i think this
was that this was the news on uh
i'm pretty sure we already had this news
on friday we knew this but micaiah
bryant
and two other young women argued over a
messy house
an unmade bed before a fight that ended
with
fatal police shooting of the black
teenager um
so the story we were getting all of last
week right was that
someone had come she was defending her
life someone had come to jump her or
something like that she was defending
herself
well we we knew from the from the
footage that that wasn't true um
and now we know it's this according to
people who were there
that uh some some other some some four
former foster kids had come
and they were getting into an argument
they were accusing mikaya bryant
of of uh not of not making her bed
and of not being neat
and so apparently she grabbed a butcher
knife and tried to stab them to death
for that
and the way that cnn and the media
presents this it's as if they think it
makes micaiah bryant more sympathetic
and the police less sympathetic
but i don't think that's the case at all
now again as i as i said all last week
you know when it when it's a 16 year old
kid
and they are a kid at 16 i believe
that's why i don't want to let lower the
voting age to 16.
unlike the left you know whether or not
a 16 year old counts as a kid really
depends on the situation for me
16 year old is a kid
so a six year old kid is at the point
where
you accuse them of not making their bed
properly and they try to stab you to
death
well that says a lot not just about them
but
people around them a lot of that blame
if you've got a six-year-old kid who
flies into a homicidal rage
over anything but especially over that
uh that's a statement about
their family life apparently it's not a
statement about the cops
but mostly about the parents and
speaking of which abc news
has a story about um bryant's
family and their calls for you know
brian's family is now coming out and
they're calling for
they're weighing legal action of course
and uh i'm sure they're thinking about
what lawsuits they can they can file
but also they're calling for reform to
the police that's what they're thinking
here
that obviously our daughter tried to
stab someone to death over an argument
over a messy room
and that means that the police need to
be reformed so here's a story from
abc news tonight growing cries to
re-evaluate police use of force policies
in the wake of the shooting death of
ohio 16 year old micaiah bryant
we recently have shooting after shooting
at the shooting
so maybe the training is wrong
protesters hitting the streets again
today the fifth straight day since the
shooting happened
bryant's family telling me the police
need to change
they have the power right now to put
some changes in the book
regardless of the situation we have to
be able to do better
and protecting life this week the
columbus division of police released
body camera footage of the incident
officer nicholas reardon firing four
shots as bryant appears to lunge at the
woman in pink with a knife
she had a knife she just went at her
columbus officers
are authorized to fire their weapons if
there's a deadly threat
an independent investigation is now
underway to determine whether the
shooting was justified
fast facts cannot come at the expense of
complete
accurate facts but while we push for
answers and transparency and
accountability
we can't lose sight of the history of
trauma and pain
in our black community yeah we actually
with this story we can lose sight of
that we can
because it's got nothing to do with
anything
so even a lot of the people who have
basically the right perspective on this
particular case
which of course the right perspective is
that the cops did cop did nothing wrong
and as a hero for uh
saving someone's life was about to be
stabbed to death but even the people
who are many of the people who are
basically there
most of them still feel the need to
throw in something like you just heard
there
yeah the cop didn't do anything wrong
but you know we can't we can't lose
sight of the overall issue of systemic
racism and
the trauma and pain of the black
community
no we could talk about systemic racism
and whether that exists which it doesn't
another time but for this issue
we can actually lose sight of all of
that because it's got
nothing to do with anything
this was an isolated circumstance
wherein a police officer
walked onto a scene and like five
seconds later
faster than that probably there was a
woman trying to stab
people to death and so he responded
he's not stopping to think about the
trauma and pain of the black community
he's not thinking about systemic racism
he's responding to the situation
and as far as trauma and pain goes
having one or two people stabbed to
death in a broad daylight out in their
driveway
i would say there might be some trauma
and pain to come from that
meanwhile just just to show you how if
you didn't already realize
how absurd the the anti-police
people in order to make their case
most of the time they're not even going
to give you the numbers they're not
going to give you the statistics at
all it's going to be all emotion all the
time
you know because when you look at the
numbers of course there's there's
no evidence at all that uh there's a
problem of racist cops out there
executing black people
but we're told that it doesn't matter if
the stats don't show it i
i feel like you know black american
feels as though this is the reality and
so it is
usually that's how they deal with the
statistics is by not looking at them at
all
but if they do look at the statistics
then they're going to have to take them
wildly out of context
and and so here's an example matthew
dowd
pundit tweeted this couple days ago over
the weekend he says
over the last 20 years the average
number of officers killed in the line of
duty is 65
per year the average number of civilian
killings by officers
is 1100 per year so tell me again who is
under greater threat
living their lives now this
so okay 65 a year verse uh versus 1100
so clearly the answer is the civilians
are
under a greater threat if you're an
idiot
and you don't stop to think about this
for even
two seconds maybe that argument is
convincing
but then when you do stop it think you
think wait a second
huh aren't there a lot more
civilians than there are police officers
like a lot more how many civilians do we
have in this country how many
how many citizens overall do we have
this country 330 million or so
are there also 330 million police
officers is there one police officer for
every
civilian
no it's you got 30 million
give or take citizens not counting
illegal aliens
and then 1100 per year killed by cops
okay and then you've got how many police
officers
i don't have the number in front of me
but it's i think it's
total like 600 000 or something
um actually i do have the number from me
okay 700 000 around 700 000 cops
total in the country so then you run the
numbers on that and what you have
a percent killed by cops among citizens
is .0003 percent
whereas among cops it's 0.009 percent
small percentage in both very small
percentage of both cases thankfully
but in terms of percentages and the
numbers we're dealing with point zero
zero nine is
significantly higher than point zero
zero zero three
so to answer matthew dowd's question
who's under a greater threat living
their lives well the cops
and that of course isn't even taking
into account the circumstances
around which those 1100 people are
killed
when you do look at those circumstances
you you discover that in almost
all of those cases it's a pretty
straightforward situation where you had
a
a suspect a violent criminal trying to
kill a police officer
most of the time by firing guns at them
shooting at them and then they get shot
in the process
but that's how bad that's that's how
you know baseless
the the anti-cop position is
that even if you take context out of it
and you pretend for a moment that all
1100 people killed by cops in a year
all of them were unarmed and uh
and totally innocent which is not even
close to true
but even if you pretended that was true
the numbers still wouldn't support the
kind of epidemic that they're uh
claiming at least in terms of
percentages
all right uh number two the oscars were
last night
didn't watch a single second of it
and uh if if you did i don't know why
you don't value your own time more than
that
if you didn't then you probably don't
care who won but i'll tell you anyway
we'll go through it we'll go through the
list of at least a few of the winners
here
actor in a leading role anthony hopkins
won for the father
never heard of that i've heard of
anthony hopkins never heard of the
father
actor in a supporting role the winner
was daniel
kaluya for judas and the black messiah
i heard about that when it was nominated
don't know anything else about it
actress in a leading role is francis
mcdormand for nomad land i've heard of
that i haven't nobody has seen it no one
actually knows what happens in that
movie because nobody's seen it
actress in a supporting role you jung
yoon
in a movie called minari
i have no idea what any of that means um
animated feature film
soul one that's the pixar movie i do
know that one
cinematography the winner was mank
who no one has seen any of these
documentary okay the winner for the
documentary was my octopus teacher which
is a documentary um
as it sounds there about an octopus that
one i have seen
and that is pretty excellent i have to
say
a little bit strange you know i i think
octopuses are are fascinating creatures
and i'm big into nature documentaries
so especially about marine life
so i did enjoy that the relationship
that the guy
forms with the octopus is is a it's a
little intense
you know it's more intense than you
would think
a relationship between a man and octopus
would be but but overall
really fascinating that's the o
of all of the the nominees and winners
the only one that i've really heard of
and seen is the documentary about the
octopus
great um now and you know
the criticism here is that while the
oscars
these days they only nominate these kind
of artsy movies that nobody's seen
and it's very elitist and you know
they're not nominating the movies that
everyone watches and likes
and i agree with that criticism to an
extent
but we also have to in fairness to the
oscars the other problem is that
all of the big movies that everybody
watches all of the big tentpole
blockbusters
all of them now are franchise films and
superhero movies
and almost all of those movies are total
garbage
and certainly don't deserve to win any
awards whatsoever
so the problem is that just a lot of
really bad movies are coming out whether
they're the blockbusters or the artsy
movies that only five people have seen
all right number three this is pretty
horrifying here's representative katie
porter talking to uh greater greta
thunberg
and i'm not sure why she's talking to
gregory thielberg but she is and she
reveals how
she porter is emotionally and
psychologically abusing her own daughter
let's listen to this
i told my nine-year-old daughter that i
was going to be speaking with you and i
said what do you think about
the climate change climate change and
she said
the earth is on fire and we're all going
to die soon
and i asked her how that made her feel
and she said it made her feel
angry what should i tell my daughter
and how should i help her and the
youngest generation
bear the emotional toll of
the actions that we're taking fossil
fuel companies are taking to destroy our
planet
well it's thank you for a question um
that's a big big question and i know
that
there are many young people who feel
angry
and sad because of all the things that
some people
are are doing okay shut up credit let me
uh let me answer that can i jump in here
let me actually answer that question for
representative porter
what do you tell your daughter when she
says she's afraid because the earth is
on fire and everyone's gonna die
well you lunatic you tell her
that that's not true and she's gonna be
okay
that's what you tell a child when
they're afraid
especially when they're afraid of
something that legitimately isn't true
there's nothing to think about it it's
it's it would be like if i went into
my daughter's room at night because
she's crying
and i say what's wrong and she tells me
daddy there's monsters under the bed
what if i were to respond oh there's
monsters under your bed how does that
make you feel
it makes me feel really scared yeah it
is scary
well anyway i'm gonna hit the sack see
you later good luck with the monsters
no what you tell your daughter is no
there's no monsters in there let me i'll
go look i'll go check i'll fight the
monsters if there's any
oh no there's no monsters you're okay
everything will be fine
daddy's here you'll be okay
i mean the fear that the earth is on
fire and that we're all gonna die of
climate change
is as ludicrous as the fear that they're
monsters under the bed
but you can't blame a child for having
ludicrous fears they're they're children
and if you've told them this then what
else are they supposed to think i mean
unfortunately katie porter's parents
are rather children have katie porter as
a parent and sadly they're going to
believe whatever katie porter tells them
it's not until they're older and they're
out of the house when they can start to
realize that their mother was a
abusive lunatic
manipulating them
the earth is on come on you know what
i have a lot of fears for for my own
children which i talk about all the time
i i worry very much about the world that
they're going to live in i worry about
the culture they're going to live in
i worry about the country that we're
leaving for them i worry about all of
those things
but i am not worried that climate change
is going to kill them
not anywhere on my list of worries
they'll be perfectly fine as far as that
goes
as far as everything else i don't know
but you know what even even my my my
valid worries and concerns
i'm not telling my kids about that there
are a lot of
really real things out there in the
world to be worried about
you know there are a lot of things out
there in the world that could harm my
kids
could kill them god forbid could could
uh
corrupt them could all kinds of things
could ruin their lives i mean there are
there's a lot
a lot of terrible things that could
happen to them that's the reality
i'm not telling them that
they don't know about almost any of it
because i they don't need to know
right now they're with me
and my wife we're there to protect them
eventually we won't be so over time you
start to introduce them to some of these
realities but
at the age of six seven eight
no need
you could protect them from those
realities and you could you can protect
them from the realities
as a parent and you could especially
protect them from things that are not a
reality
such as the concern that climate change
is going to destroy the earth because
it's not
all right um speaking of things that are
not a reality this is from the new york
post it says
social distancing inside at 60 feet
is no safer than at six feet and
exposure time indoors is actually far
more important according to a new study
from the massachusetts
institute of technology in a report that
challenges widely accepted covet 19
prevention guidelines
researchers say there's little benefit
to health officials six-foot rule
especially when wearing masks inside uh
mit engineering professor martin
bezant said the distancing isn't helping
you that much and it's also giving you a
false sense of security
because you're as safe at six feet as
you are at 60 feet if you're indoors
everyone in that space is at roughly the
same risk actually
during the study researchers calculated
exposure risk to the virus
based on factors such as amount of time
spent inside
air filtration and circulation according
to the study
they also looked at factors such as mask
use immunization and respiratory
activity such as breathing eating and
speaking
and it's an interesting article you
could go and read the whole thing but um
so what they're saying six foot this is
that's not based on in any on anything
you're six feet away from someone or 60
feet basically the same thing
and i think that was obvious to a lot of
us from the beginning
because they just pulled the six-foot
rule
out of thin air and so why did they
decide on six feet well because it's a
that was as far as they felt they could
enforce
that's all it was it was an enforcement
calculation now whether there was any
good reason to be enforcing anything at
all
that that wasn't considered it was just
decided that okay we need to
separate people and uh let's come up
with a distance
that we think we can reasonably try to
enforce
it and of course for them reasonable
includes
shutting down the whole economy
destroying thousands of businesses
in one fell swoop for them that's a
that's a reasonable thing that they can
do and they did
but of course they did of course there
was no science behind it
they came up with this rule on the spot
early on i mean what kind of studies did
anyone think they could have done at
that point
you know the irony here is as it says in
the article
um the real kicker is exposure time it's
how
how much time are you spending inside
with someone who's infected
no matter how close you are to them
so if you have an infected person in in
your family and you're in your home
and you're inside with them all hours of
the day then there's a really good
chance you're going to get sick no
matter matter how close
you are to them and what that means is
that
rather than all of these cities and
states
shutting down their parks shutting down
their playgrounds
you know telling you that if you want to
go walk the dog you can only be out for
seven and a half minutes and you got to
go back inside
rather than doing that they should have
been they should have been telling
people no get outside as much as
possible go out to the park
open up the parks build more parks for
people
if anything
that's what should have been done but
instead they forced everyone to stay
inside which increased exposure time and
then
people got each other sick brilliant
brilliant strategy
all right finally this is a tweet from
senator schumer
he says excited to be watching the
oscars with an ice-cold plant-based beer
thanks joe biden now i'm not sure what
this is referring to
this must be some kind of attempt at a
joke referencing some dumb thing or
another i don't know
obviously all beer is plant-based first
of all a meat-based beer sounds kind of
interesting but
not the kind of thing you'd probably
want to you know maybe you try that one
a bacon-based beer i don't know if that
exists i try it
not your everyday sipper kind of beer
but my problem is
look at this picture here he's he's in a
wooden chair
sitting two feet from the screen holding
the beer like it's the first time he's
ever held a beer in his life
this is what happens and he's watching
the oscars of all things
who says who sits in a chair like that
you're lounging at night you're watching
tv you're sitting in a wooden chair
right next to the screen
this is what happens when when these
half half-humanoid automatons that we've
elected to
to uh to office when they try to act
like real people this is what you end up
with
is this well done i guess he thinks he's
dunking on conservatives there i'm not
sure how or
why but uh but there it is well done
chuck schumer
all right let's move on to reading the
youtube comments this is from eugene
says love you brother this black
american is all about personal
accountability yeah if we're going to
talk about lebron james
is is out there shouting accountability
accountability
i think accountability is a great idea i
think we need more of that i agree with
you eugene
personal accountability first and
foremost well
personal accountability and um and
another p word parental accountability
those are the two forms of
accountability that we need
um another comment says i actually saw
an arrest playing out today the one
being arrested appeared to be a black
man he didn't resist
answered all the cops questions and what
do you know he wasn't shot
it is it's crazy it's crazy how it
almost always works out that way
you're being arrested because you
committed a crime or you're suspected of
committing a crime
you don't resist arrest you fight the
charge in court
you'll live to tell the tale in almost
every case black or white
um another comment we live in an era of
narcissistic
nature we've emboldened this idea of me
first and now we have multiple
generations that believe the lie that
they are uniquely important
that young girl was never taught that
you have to respect authority
whether you like it or not yeah mikaya
bryant
obviously not taught to respect
authority but
you know the greater problem is that it
doesn't seem like mackay bryant was
taught anything at all
from a parenting perspective it doesn't
seem like there was really any parental
influence she was in foster care after
all
and her mother is living and apparently
lives down the street
so she wasn't taught how to respect
authority she wasn't taught
anything and that's how you end up with
a 16 year old trying to stab someone to
death
over a fight over you know who makes the
bed
um another says we have grown to love
the polka dot shirt matt
well then that means i guess i have to
stop wearing it that's
you're not supposed to love it you're
supposed to grow to hate it more and
more which each with each passing week
that's the punishment
um this is kind of like i'm going
through what i go through with my kids
now where where your kids get to a
certain age where
sending them to their room isn't really
a punishment anymore
because it just gives them a break and
kind of gives them some time to
themselves and they can play with their
toys
gotta think of different punishment i
guess um but no i'm still gonna wear the
polkadot shirt i said a year and i'm
gonna do it
finally another comment says hey man i'm
a travel nurse on assignment in austin
texas right now i came to ut to hear you
speak and unfortunately was one of the
many with a ticket who couldn't get in
due to the coveted restrictions
i was upset but ultimately laughed at
the irony of not being let in to hear
you speak due to covet
i wasn't nearly as upset as the guy in
front of me who drove from houston to
hear you
looking forward to hopefully hopefully
catching you speak in the future yeah i
feel
terrible about that i heard a lot of
these stories
after i was done you know i'm i was
speaking at ut austin last week
and um i'm giving my speech blissfully
unaware of what's going on in the
hallway and apparently there were
lots of people that were that came out
had tickets were turned away by the
university because of coveted
restrictions
and and just because because what the
university decided is that
speaking of arbitrary guidelines you
know we know six feet is arbitrary
they also decided that only 99 people
could be a part of the event
99 was the cap couldn't go beyond 99
people
uh because we all know right as long as
you don't get into triple digits
once you get the triple digits that's
when kovid activates and everyone's
going to get sick
um but to give you an idea of how
ridiculous this was 99 people
um and what that meant was you could
only have 99 people
participate in the event no matter where
they were
on the campus so for example we had a
really big open room right next to us
where we could have had some overflow
capacity
but that would count against the 99. so
if you had
if there were 99 people in the room and
one person
sitting in a 300 person room next door
watching it on on a tv screen or
listening to it
that would that would be above the limit
according to the university
even though they're in the next room
so those were the rules i apologize to
all the people that got turned away they
really do
um i i hope we can get to a point soon
enough where we can
just do events and not have to worry
about this anymore quick word now from
charity mobile we're about to talk about
in the daily cancellation
uh yet another awoke company and why we
should probably
consider you know not giving our money
to all these companies that hate our
guts
uh and if we're if we're taking our
money away from the companies that hate
us how about giving that money
uh some of it to companies that actually
support us in the culture
like charity mobile one company that
certainly fits the description here is
charity mobile the pro-life phone
company five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the pro-life
pro-family charity of your choice
and there's also a lot of great perks as
well that you get with this company new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk at all
with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so um there's no
reason to
not at least try charity mobile out see
how much you love the service and you
will love it
and by the way they've got live customer
service based right here in the usa
you're also getting free usage alerts
you get a free app to monitor
your usage pay your bill and everything
which i've found to be really helpful
all all the while you are helping to
build a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company so
call them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them online at charitymobile.com
well another high energy episode of
candace is coming at you this friday
this week
candace hosts political commentator and
interviewer dave rubin
uh where they'll of course going to have
a lot to discuss including the recall
election of california governor
gavin newsom and his new opponent
caitlyn jenner you can subscribe now and
stream
candace live on fridays at 9 pm eastern
8 pm central only on daily wire
and get 25 off a new membership with
code candice at dailywire.com
subscribe now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to a viral article in the orlando
sentinel the piece is written by guest
contributor jonathan
van boskirk with the headline i love
disney world but wokeness is ruining the
experience
and it begins this way he says my family
and i have been loyal disney customers
for decades we vacation at disney world
every year we take a disney cruise every
year or two
consequently we spend way too much money
in orlando unfortunately i'm strongly
rethinking our commitment to disney and
thus orlando
the more disney moves away from the
values and vision of walt disney the
less disney world means to me
disney is forgetting that guest
immersion is at the core of its business
model
when i stand in galaxy's edge or fantasy
land
uh i know i'm in a theme park but
through immersion and my willingness to
set the real world aside
something magical happens that spell is
broken when the immersive experience is
shattered by the real world
and boy has disney been breaking the
immersion
okay now now already we we have a
problem because
a grown man is describing disney world
as magical
it's arguable whether a grown man ought
to be calling anything magical
unless the thing is literally magical
like if you stumble across a lamp with a
with an actual genie inside it or
something you could call that magical
but certainly
that sort of sentiment should should not
be applied to a theme park
i've been to plenty of theme parks and
at this point in my life they do not put
me under any sort of spell if i'm
immersed in anything it's the thought of
how much
damned money i'm spending for the
privilege of standing in a series of
long lines while listening to kids
to kids other people's and my own
whining about the line the heat
they want a snack et cetera et cetera as
i said this article went viral and most
people
are criticizing the writer um but not
for the reason that i'm criticizing him
i take issue with mr van boskirk
primarily because adult men
shouldn't like disney world so much or
at all
and i've made this point before and i've
been told by other adult men
that i'm nothing but a curmudgeon for
saying this because
disney world is the happiest place on
earth and how could i hate the happiest
place on earth
now i am indeed a commercial but even so
a place that trademarks itself as the
happiest place on earth
and charges you hundreds of dollars to
experience that happiness
is certain to be anything but the
happiest place on earth
for me it's not like i don't have any
happy place for me
the happiest place on earth for me is a
quiet lake
at 6 a.m with a coffee mug and a fishing
rod
second happiest is the same lake 12
hours later with a beer instead of a
coffee
that for me that's the happiest it's
quiet it's free it's peaceful
the idea of trading that in for a theme
park
is repugnant to me on a deep and
visceral
level no way that's my problem with this
article
that's my problem with it everyone else
seems to be taking issue with this part
where he writes quote recently disney
announced that cast members are now
permitted to display
tattoos wear inclusive uniforms and
display inclusive haircuts
disney did all of this in the name of
allowing cast members to express
themselves
the problem is i'm not traveling across
the country and paying thousands of
dollars to watch someone i don't know
express themselves
i'm therefore i am there for the
immersion and the fantasy
not the reality of a stranger's
self-expression i do not begrudge these
people their individuality and i wish
them well in their personal lives
but i don't get to express my
individuality at my place of business
what's next is disney going to end the
rule barring on stage cell phone use by
cast members as an infringement on
self-expression
now people are mocking the writer for
this passage but he's actually 100
correct about this part of it
i personally have no stake in the
uniform requirements for disney
princesses but
as a neutral third party i can say yes
this is stupid
it if your job is to pretend to be the
little mermaid or whoever
then that's your job nobody cares about
your self-expression nobody goes to
disney and pays all that money to see
you know sarah johnson from lakeland
florida express herself
they're not going for that they they
want to see the little mermaid that's
why they're there
why they go to see the little mermaid is
a different question why grown men go to
see the little mermaid is definitely a
whole separate question but
that's what they're doing that's what
they want and your job is to give them
what they want it'd be like if i worked
at mcdonald's and i decided that
i was going to personally change the
recipe of the big mac in order to
express myself
if i said you know i i just i'm giving
out these big macs all day and i i just
can't i can't communicate my inner
feelings
through this big mac recipe i'm gonna
change it
see the problem is the people in the
drive-thru line they're not there to get
matt walsh's twist on the big mac
they're there for the big mac the same
big mac they've always had
and my job is to give them that again
there's the same question as to why
anyone would want that product but
if you work there it's not your place to
be asking those questions
it is not to reason why it is but to do
and die
that wisdom from the charge of the light
brigade applies both to military units
and disney world
employees in my mind so on this point i
agree with mr
van boskirk he continues
more broadly like many corporations
disney has been politicizing its
business
disney is in the process of taking the
woke scalpel to the jungle cruise
trader sam is out because he might
offend certain people
every grown up in the room realizes that
traitor sam is not a representation of
reality
and is meant as a funny and silly
caricature it's no more based in racism
than every disney character
of an out-of-touch white american dad
side note
no grown-ups don't know who traitor sam
is that's that's the grown-up
perspective on this but anyway
the next time i ride jungle cruise i
will not be thinking about the
gloriously entertaining puns of the
skippers i will be thinking about
disney's political agenda
that's a mood killer disney proclaims
that splash mountain must change because
it's
because of its association with song of
the south
disney owns splash mountain so it can do
what it wants
but if disney screams at the top of its
corporate voice which is pretty loud
that it's changing it to appease a
certain political point of view now
every time i look at that ride i'm
thinking about politics
the same with pirates of the caribbean
disney has made significant changes to
pirates of the caribbean over the years
whether
disney caved to political pressure or
really thought the alterations were
necessary is irrelevant
finally it concludes with this disney
world is going to lose us as customers
if it continues down this path
i don't want to have disney world taken
away from us because disney cares more
about politics than happy guests
disney please return to the values and
vision of walt
the customer experience should be the
core of your business model immersion
should not be sacrificed on the altar of
political correctness
and appeasing the twitter mob okay
now i join in uh in i joined the writer
in opposing the wokification
and pcification of pop culture i agree
with the general sentiment
though again you wouldn't have this
problem if you were out on the lake
like a man but this man and uh
every other conservative needs to
understand something
disney like so many other companies
hates your guts that is not going
to change disney hates you
despises you it will gladly take your
money
if you insist on pushing your money into
its hand if you continue to empty your
wallet right into disney's grubby paws
it'll be happy to oblige they'll put
their hands out and sure go ahead give
me all your money
but it hates you and giving disney your
money begrudgingly
scowling and complaining while you do it
that doesn't accomplish anything
money is money you don't achieve
anything by saying gosh darn it disney
i'm not happy with you i'm i'm really
miffed about this oh how much was that
646
okay here you go anyway i am so
displeased with you disney
that message just lacks a certain uh
weight i guess
the only thing that will make a
difference make a dent is if you
withhold your money completely
again disney hates the majority of its
customers
if all of those customers said okay well
screw you too then
and took their money elsewhere things
would change
but if you aren't willing to do that
then there's no point in complaining
so we have to make a decision okay
it's decision time either we can shut up
and be good in cooperative little
consumers and open our mouths and
uh and consume whatever they serve to us
whatever whatever heaping pile of toxic
sludge
they put in front of our faces we could
just dive right in
or we can be discerning and intentional
in how we spend our money
no those are the choices if we choose
the former then we might as well stop
whining and go with the flow
whichever the case it's time to choose
door one or door two
the writer of this article seems to want
to have it both ways and so he is
canceled
also a lot of his critics are cancelled
for disagreeing with his correct points
they disagreed with him for the wrong
reasons and so they're cancelled
and disney is cancelled too and the
disney princesses with tattoos
also cancelled everyone is canceled
as it should be and we'll leave it there
for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. caitlyn jenner kicks off his
campaign for governor
the media make a golden idol out of
fouchy an actual literal golden idol
and elon musk laughs about how many
people will die on the first mission to
mars check it out on the michael knowles
[Music]
show